that's like eight hundred thousand
dollars of recurring Revenue if I get
two and a half percent that's two
million if I do five percent that's four
million and if you just think about what
would I pay for a business that makes me
that much money a year like this is like
five ten fifteen million dollars of
value and so I'm looking at it and going
this is great I'd pay for what I'm
getting
[Music]
all right what's going on everyone we
have Andrew Wilkinson on the Pod today
Andrew's one of our great great friends
he runs this company called tiny which
is publicly traded in Canada it's a
holding company that owns like 40
different companies I think it's
publicly traded at like a 800 million
dollar market cap something like that
does 150-ish in a year in Revenue so
he's got a really good insight and we
talked to him about a few interesting
things one thing that sounds kind of
like not that cool but actually is cool
is he hung out with a few folks that are
worth like 10 or 20 billion dollars
recently and he like talked about what
it's like hanging out with people uh in
that sphere uh we talked about meta lab
which was his agency that he started
which provided all the profits in order
to start tiny and how it makes something
like 20 million dollars a year in profit
and we just said how the hell does it
make so much money and what did you guys
do so he gives us a breakdown on that uh
we also asked them which agency he would
start now we asked him all about his new
Twitter experience so why would somebody
who is worth all this money run a
Twitter experiment that makes 10 or 20
grand a month in sales and he gives it's
a low down on how much money his uh that
little experiment's making and then we
asked him about when you take dividends
from a company like what do you actually
do with the dividends and where do you
invest them or how much do you pay
yourself and he got really transparent
about that and so it was really
interesting so check it out this is
Andrew Wilkinson it's Sean and me Sam so
if you guys like it subscribe on YouTube
subscribe on your Spotify subscribe on
wherever podcasts are and uh let us know
if you liked it see you soon
I was uh before you got on channels make
it for the badger he looks like Kevin
McAllister's mom in Home Alone
mom mom
he looks like he uh he looks like he's
uh just taking up rollerblading in the
night in the 90s
you're saying I look like Catherine
O'Hara well look at her character in The
Home Alone she had a massive wave it was
cool
you're like a bully in a movie I think
you look good I think it's cool it's
okay man she was hot she was hot it's
all right
um well welcome back there's no podcast
on Earth where you will just be welcomed
with open insults like my first million
yeah this is great you guys want to
roast me for another 10 minutes uh yeah
I was I was supposed to come on what
like three weeks ago and then I got
strep throat and dude I haven't been
that sick in years I was like on death's
door for a year I ended up taking like
three different antibiotics so I'm I'm
glad to be alive and you're on a health
kick now you've been lifting weights
yeah yeah I'm doing a muscle gain
competition with a bunch of friends so
that's been really fun Sean says he's
Sean has like I think 40 days left to
have abs how many days do you have left
I'm just I say I'm perpetually eight
weeks away from having exactly the body
I want the problem is it's a this clock
restarts every time um doordash you know
Domino's or Taco Bell or something like
that so have you tried just doing a
zenpic because like I I have so many
friends that are taking that and it's
just like they're suddenly ripped yeah
there's it just doesn't have it doesn't
do it for me Sean's very anti like are
you would you are you are you a vaccine
are you an anti-vaccine guy too no but I
do think that uh the covered vaccine was
not a vaccine because I was like wait a
minute so you still get it you still
spread it
all right well I that doesn't sound like
Mexican to me you're like anti-putting
stuff in your body it seems I don't
drink caffeine I don't uh take like
I guess I take some supplements like
I'll take uh protein powder or whatever
but uh yeah I try not to be dependent on
anything and you know the weight loss
thing for me I'm already married I got
two kids I don't really care to lose
weight uh aside from
conquering my mind and doing something
that I wanted to do so if I took ozempic
to do it it would not uh be satisfying
in the way that it will be when I just
do it myself
yeah I've just always told myself at one
point in my life I want to look like
Wolverine even if it's like for one week
and then it's over and it's
unsustainable or whatever I just want to
get there I want to have the photo to
prove it
um so that's my goal for the next year
or you should do the um the Jesse itzler
living with a seal thing I feel like
that's uh in play for you why aren't you
doing that that sounds so freaking
miserable that was the David Goggins
thing yeah did you read that with them
no I just remember you guys had them on
you gotta you gotta read that book it's
pretty good it's a fun it's a fun it's
called living living with and seal or
something living with seal
he writes it almost like a diary so it's
just sort of like you know it's not like
a long book with like a bunch of Flowery
language it's very simple
um and you know it's like any David
Geiger gets you motivated but this is
like secondhand Gaga you don't even
realize the guy is David Goggins because
he doesn't say it in the book and you're
reading the perspective not of David
Goggins telling you that you're soft and
you need to be hard but like a guy who
was kind of soft getting yelled at by
David goggin so you're sort of
secondhand at receiving the info have
you guys seen the cover of this book it
looks like you know remember like Ernest
Goes to Camp it looks like the cover of
like Ernest very outdated
well we and we're having the guy Jesse
on the Pod soon he's scheduled and I was
thinking about it Sean we've asked our
question of like who's like who has the
ideal life he's up there man he's he's
kind of nailed it well that's his thing
the life resume what does he do so he
just like has these experiments or
whatever I know he went and lived with
monks and he's done the Navy SEAL thing
well before that he was like I think he
like initially made a little bit of
money by having like I think he had like
a rap group and he like made songs for
like the New York Knicks and he like
that was his career was writing Jingles
try to be a rapper was like all right
maybe he can't be like rapper rapper but
I could be like commercial jingle rapper
hit it with that made a couple million
bucks like sold the company for like
four million dollars then he created the
fractional jet share company uh Marquee
Jets him and his buddy and then they
sold that to netjets which Buffett owns
and then uh he married the co-founder of
Spanx
um or the founder of Spain and she's
like a billionaire yeah and then he also
created like uh a coconut what's it
called he bought
uh coconut water is even coconut water
zico ziko coconut water
um early on and then help them sell to
Coke so he basically just goes like kind
of like Mission or passion uh to Passion
but he's had like pretty good results
like he owns a part of an NBA team he
was like Oh I wanna I'm Into Fitness so
he creates this running club he actually
reminds me a little bit of you in that
like I feel like you experiment
uh like you like to experiment and
you'll get into your experiments and the
experiments almost start it's almost
like oh why is Andrew doing this almost
silly thing but it's because there's
something in you that's like you've
identified something that you're like
right now Jesse it's like I love pickles
and there's no great pickle company so
he's like scouring the Earth to find the
best pickle company to buy because he's
like there's a big opportunity of
pickles and he's like I can't believe
you guys are all sleeping well there's a
pickle opportunity like this and I just
find it amazing how he's getting really
into these like Niche passion Pursuits
but then kind of pulls them off in an
epic way I think I think it's really
cool I mean I think we talked about him
before but Nick Gray any of these people
that build their life around the thing
they actually love doing because I feel
like so many of us were like okay I want
to get rich I want to build a big
business or whatever and so you get into
doing something but you don't actually
necessarily like a lot of those tasks
you do or if you can build a business
where your job is like to meet
interesting people or be a podcaster and
speak to really interesting people all
the time time or do these crazy life
experiments I think that's awesome but I
think it's a double-edged sword I've
made that mistake where I will get into
a hobby or something like that and I'll
turn it into a business and it will take
the joy out of it so I think it's a
little it's a little hard to find that
that right uh in between spot well
that's why I didn't want to do that
Twitter thing because so you're doing
Twitter subscribers you have like a
community now I think you I don't know
if you'll say the revenue or not but
it's like actually kind of a business
six figures a year in Revenue
are you enjoying that you you told me
you're doing it and I was like I don't
want to do that that sounds hard yeah
yeah well let me let me explain so yeah
so I have about 240 000 Twitter
followers I've never monetized it anyway
I just you know I tweet every day and
it's literally like I'm in the shower or
I'm on the toilet and I think think of
something and I tweeted out that's
always been my life on Twitter
um and it's been amazing like I've met
tons of interesting people from it but
the issue is and I know both you guys
have this problem too
you get endless reach outs from all
these people constantly and for a while
I had open DMS it was just overwhelming
I was getting like 100 DMS from random
people pitching me on like crypto scams
and stuff but every like 25 people would
be some incredible 22 year old who has
this amazing cash flow business they
want to sell me or they need money or
something like that and so I had this
incentive to go through it and I would
spend like 30 minutes a day going
through all these and triaging them and
kind of hating my life and so when I saw
this subscription thing I was like okay
this is actually a filter so what
Twitter lets you do is have
um gated tweets so you can say anyone
who pays to subscribe to me gets these
extra tweets and so what I did is I was
like okay if someone will spend 29 bucks
which is the cost to basically buy me
lunch then they can DM me then they can
message me then I'll you know then I'll
respond and so I used it as a filter but
it kind of surprised me as I started
doing the math
um so basically what I did is I said
okay 29 bucks I'll do an AMA once a
month which you know I enjoy doing
anyway video or writing
just video like a big video group or
whatever
and then I made a telegram group and
that's it and I said I won't even
respond to the telegram group
um you know that's it you got the AMA
and my tweets or whatever but when you
do the math like it's pretty crazy I
have about 550
um paying subscribers today that's
growing pretty consistently
um that's about 16k of mrr so about 200k
a year uh it's basically pure profit I
probably spend an hour a month two hours
a month doing the AMA or whatever and if
you look at the math like a one percent
conversion rate on 200 um what is it 240
000 people that's like eight hundred
thousand dollars of recurring Revenue if
I get two and a half percent that's two
million if I do five percent that's four
million and if you just think about what
would I pay for a business that makes me
that much money a year like this is like
5 10 15 million dollars of value and so
I'm looking at it and going this is
great I'd pay for what I'm getting I'm
getting people being filtered out
dinguses are filtered out
um I'm making money and I'm actually
getting deal flow so I've like higher
I've literally hired two or three people
from this I now go to this group and I'm
like hey I need a CEO for this business
or I want to buy a business like this
and so it's been awesome
um and yeah I'm loving it Sam do you pay
to follow uh Andrew
no I will I can just text him but I will
I'm a dangerous I guess you're in the
Dingus I'm a paying subscriber so I I
are you of course all right I'll do it
are you gonna do it Sean no I'm never
gonna do this I paid literally to just
figure out why the hell is Andrew doing
this and then I my mind started going
with conspiracies I texted Andrew can I
share my conspiracy theory as to why
yeah yeah okay so I assume I sent Andrew
a voice note I go
uh this is my logic you're way too rich
to be doing this so there's got to be
another reason
I said why would why would Andrew start
using all the paid features of tour
these new paid features of X
um why would he be doing these
subscriber experiments and he's speaking
so glowingly about how this is so cool
how he's discovering his true fans how
he's getting all this value out of it
I was like this just doesn't add up it's
too much work for too little money for
this guy and so then I was like I know
what he's doing I've seen Andrew do cool
moves like this in the past where he
uses he throws his weight around in
order to meet the cool people he he
likes and admires and wants to hang out
with I said oh this is the long game
because guess who really wants cool
interesting people like Andrew using all
the paid Twitter features in order to uh
to to build a small business and and
would love that they're telling the
world how great this is
Elon freaking musk and I thought oh this
is genius actually Andrew is using this
feature on blast he's the most legit guy
who's doing this
um with a unique use case and he's got a
big following he's going to be the gold
star example he's going to get a follow
he might get a DM he might get invited
he might get invited to come out to
visit Andrew's going to end up friends
with Elon Musk from this whole thing
that's my prediction and so I I sent a
voice note to Andrew like I cracked the
case like I found you know whatever the
shooter for JFK and I was like ah I know
what you're doing you're trying to
become friends with Elon and he's like
no
uh just like yeah right and I was like
damn I almost wish that was the answer
that would have been a better answer is
that true I actually I have no and I I
um I've invested in SpaceX quite a while
ago and I have a ton of friends who are
friends with Elon and know him and stuff
I honestly I don't know what I would say
to the guy right like I feel like he's
like a super genius engineer like super
kind of Asperger Z guy I don't there's a
lot of people I would love to meet Elon
I'd love to be at a dinner table with
him but I actually don't I I don't know
what I would say to him it's like
meeting Thomas Edison like how am I
interesting to this guy who would you
like the most boring businesses uh I
really want to meet Larry Ellison I've
been trying to meet Larry Ellison for
like probably two years and I went to
Lanai and he owns the entire island of
Lanai it's insane like everything he
owns they're all the businesses all the
hotels all the real estate and while I
was there I was trying to find a mutual
connection and he kept driving by me in
here
orange
the guy the guy drives an orange
Corvette and he just rips around Lanai
and I just couldn't I couldn't meet him
but anyway he's super fascinating dude
it's so funny that from the outside so
we'll do an intro to this because we
just jumped into it but so Andrew you're
in your mid are you maybe late 30s now
30s now and very very successful company
uh in the ballpark of a billion dollars
publicly traded and you still can't meet
some people and so good looking it looks
like the mom from home alone and we
still can't get it done it's insane I
claim to fame I want it to look like
Wolverine and instead I look like the
mom from home alone I didn't tell the
story on the podcast yet but I went down
to LA
and
um I I did a bunch of these like pod
interviews that are gonna be coming out
but I did some meetings that were not
podcasts just like really interesting
people but I didn't I didn't record I
just wanted to go I went to their house
I just wanted to meet them and see what
they're like and uh one of the people so
I can't say who one of the people they
were showing me around their house is a
famous successful person in La you know
just uh use that General character
and they said something really
insightful they were talking about
trying to um get something they're
trying to get their kid into a school
and like this is a person who's rich and
famous it could kind of get anything
they want but there's you know these
schools in La there's private schools
that like they're they get their thing
is that they're like Harvard for
kindergarten they like reject everybody
and so they got rejected at the school
and he's like he's just saying this he
goes
he goes I couldn't tell you that morning
he's like I felt something that I hadn't
felt in seven years
rejection he's like nobody had told me
no in seven years and I was like wow
that's a
kind of amazing that uh you know you
sort of feel rejection and so anyway
this is my my to your Larry Ellison
point I think it's great that you have
certain things that that didn't didn't
work out or you got rejection because
when we were in La we met Maybe
20 people during the week that we had
meetings with and I would say a very
common thing was so people were out of
touch with rejection which was either
one of two things they weren't trying
enough new things so they're just in
their comfort zone or everybody around
them just said yes even to their bad
ideas even to like request it didn't
make sense and um you could see
firsthand how that's not a great thing
how you don't want to be in that
position has I I don't know if you've
been single and successful but Dan
Bilzerian has this line I actually read
the Dan Bilzerian book which is
shockingly good and he's like being
famous is so much better for meeting
girls than being rich is like it's 10
times better to be famous than it is
Rich have you found being successful has
helped you with women or do they mostly
not give a [__] uh well I haven't been I
haven't really been like single for a
very long period of time it's definitely
helped
um
but I mean I think It ultimately comes
down to status in the room you're in
right so like if you're in a club you
know the DJ the guy who's making less
than the bartender and is getting paid
in drinks he's the man he's the guy that
all the girls want to sleep with right
so I think you know whatever room you're
in and so you know if I was at like a
like a business conference and a bunch
of people knew who I was yeah maybe that
would help me with women but when it
comes to day to day I mean yeah you're
way better off being like an Instagram
influencer or something that girls
actually care about
um I think it helps though I mean it
helps to have your your [__] together
for sure uh how do you play the status
game if I had an experience recently
where somebody I know I have to be
really really vague about this somebody
I know went to someone's house who is a
billionaire that's also famous
and that person
um entertains a bunch of people during
the Summers and has a bunch of people at
their house at the same time all of
those people are also rich and famous
and the person I know was a regular
person no you know not not like uh
somebody would recognize or somebody
who's been in People magazine or
whatever
and so they felt very intimidated in
that social setting uh to the point
where they're like you know I I'm just
gonna go eat in my room because it's
like I don't really wanna I feel like if
I go here I have to engage I don't
really know how to engage they're not
gonna care about me they're really like
talking themselves out of it and
I think that's a very common situation I
know because I've definitely felt that
in a bunch of social settings I think
there's probably more common than I
realized I thought when it when I
experienced it I thought this was
something that was just happening in my
head then as this person was telling me
about it I realized okay this probably
happens to a lot of people
how do you guys deal with that like kind
of social anxiety where
you're in your own head about the status
of the people in the room and how you
fit in and where where you fit I've just
realized that everybody wants to talk
about themselves and it's the Dale
Carnegie thing find out what someone
likes to talk about and then talk to
them about that and just keep asking
questions and I realize that if they if
I make them feel good if they get to
talk about the thing that they're
interested in they will leave that
experience thinking of me as a very
positive person regardless of status
have you read that book Sean do you know
what he's talking about yeah I I have
yeah there's like a famous story where
this like young guy is hanging out with
this like rich guy who has the power and
the young guy just asks questions for 90
minutes of the 100 minutes and at the
last 10 minutes the rich guy finally
like asked him just a little bit and the
rich guy leaves conversation being like
that was the best conversation I've ever
had that person sure is great and the
other you know the nobody was like dude
I barely said anything that literally
happens to Ben Ben the business partner
all the time he'll come back from a
meeting and I'm like how'd it go he's
like yeah it's great guys you know I ask
a bunch of questions uh you know he's
like he literally I really didn't tell
him anything I didn't say anything he
didn't really ask me too much he's like
uh I just asked him so many questions
that I was interested in about him he's
like at the end of it the guy stood up I
was like man this is one of the best
conversations ever I really like you and
I was like you did it again like you
know he is that he's like the walking
version of that book and you leave and
you're like you know nothing about me
you didn't ask any questions and I think
it's great if the person is really
fascinating what the status stuff though
where I get annoyed is
um so I remember I was at a conference
uh probably like 13 years ago and at
this point my business is making you
know a couple million bucks a year uh in
profit you know it's pretty successful
and I sit down at this table next to
this VC and he seems very disinterested
and you know then he says what is what
does your startup do and I say well I
don't have a startup I have a business
and it's profitable and he literally
just goes oh a lifestyle business and it
turns his back you just literally just
turns his belt away from me and just
starts talking to the guy next to him
and I remember who it is I will one day
there's gonna be like a comeuppance
moment but I always think about that and
then the other thing that happened to me
recently
um so I was on this yacht I'll tell you
guys about that later if you want do it
now okay so so basically um
I got I got invited to go on like 100
million dollar plus uh yacht which I was
actually really really excited about
um just always been curious like it's
this bizarre thing that you know you
really don't get to see very often
um and so I thought I'd love it but I
actually found it incredibly odd
um it's something that I feel like is
very desirable because others desire it
and we all have this idea of it but in
reality I just don't get it like you
spend this insane amount of money to be
isolated in a floating Hotel away from
all the plebs basically right what was
the what was the net worth of the guy in
order to have a hundred million yeah
you're worth like five or ten billion 20
billion plus like very very very wealthy
guy
um I won't I won't say who but someone
who's like a subscriber of yours on
Twitter let's just say somebody yeah
that's right exactly
um but you know you know like you do you
ever like you ever have that feeling of
like
um you know you're on this you're on
this like floating Hotel it's shaking
rattling it's swaying lightly which is
like in my opinion not not nice and then
you like have you ever been like on a
really really nice RV like you go on one
of those bus RVs and you're like holy
crap I can't believe this RV has like
the shower I can't believe it has like a
king-sized bed but at the end of the day
it's an RV king size bed it's not as
nice as being in a hotel and I felt like
that's the rich person equivalent right
like everything on this boat is amazing
but it's not as nice as staying in a
Four Seasons and it's a hundred times
the cost and you've got this thing that
costs you 10 to 20 million dollars a
year to maintain no way really 30 staff
for 10 people literally this whole boat
just has 10 guests on it right it's just
crazy but anyway while I'm on this yacht
whole bunch of people there and there's
this guy who runs a publicly traded
company and
um you know I'm doing my thing I'm
asking questions and chatting with
everyone and he kind of like
um he's kind of the serious guy he seems
very unimpressed by me and he goes oh so
what's your business and I say oh I've
got a you know holding company and he
goes oh is it public and I say yes it's
public and he goes how big is it and I
go uh I don't know trading at like 800
million today and he goes oh okay and
his is like 10 billion he's like oh
lifestyle business he's haunting you
yeah exactly it was like that same
feeling right and it's like I still get
that same irritating feeling and I just
feel like I'm not gonna play I'm like
opting out I just can't deal just lifts
up his legs it just walks away
like dude soup's up
that's that's the that's the weird thing
with the status game right is like
there's no end of it there's no end like
the build I remember I was talking to a
guy who's a um multi-billionaire and he
goes oh my god um you know Laureen
Powell job Steve Jobs Widow she's so
[__] Rich she's worth like 20 billion
and I look at him and I'm like what can
you not do that she can and he kind of
goes glassy-eyed and he's like super
yacht I can't do a super yacht yet and
it's just like that is the most pathetic
insane thing but you're yet you're
falling into that trap as am I and I'm
sure Sean is as well where you know I'm
not a billionaire but I'm sure someone
looked at what you know maybe what I
have and they go why would you want more
and in my head I'm like
of course I want more and I'm angry at
myself for wanting that but it's never
enough yeah it's like leaving a party
and you go to the and you move to the
next room and then they put you back at
the kids table and you're like God I
just want to be at the adults table
right now and I just keep ending up at a
kid's table no matter what level I get
to we were at an event that was um a
basketball related event and um
I've said this before Ben has like some
facial recognition software or something
like that because he's like that guy
over there is the minority owner of this
NBA team I'm like dude how do you even
recognize the minority owners of these
teams like that I don't even know who
these people are you see them at an
event you're like that's him he's
standing alone he's talking to nobody
and um so we walk over we're like oh
let's introduce ourselves walk over
and uh introduce ourselves hey what's
going on uh I'm sorry what brings you
here you know whatever something like
that so he we kind of approach him from
the side he turns he's got two airpods
in I was like all right double airpod
all right nope that's okay he'll surely
take one out he looks at us we say the
first line he kind of just looks at us
like are you gonna leave or is there
more oh there's more okay I see him he
takes out his phone and he just slides
the volume slider down halfway
and I'm like oh [__] he's still got he
didn't even pause he's just temporarily
gave us like some airspace and we and we
we actually know a little again because
Ben knows this guy he's like oh yeah he
he's really into this and he's his
business was doing this
so I'm like asking him about his thing
for a second and you know this guy if
there was a cologne called leave me the
[__] alone he would have been spraying
it all over us in that moment it was
just so obvious what this guy did not
want to talk to us so fair enough uh we
walk away next day uh we see a picture
of him like on it on Instagram or
something like that he's smiling and we
I texted our friend who approached it
with us and I was like oh this somebody
snapped a picture of him when we walked
away like that's him smiling so bright
uh you know as that interaction was over
but I feel like it's like um you know
you have to experience these things so
that you won't do it to others right and
I always wonder like what's the moment
where I kind of did that to somebody now
like I I never want to become that show
me where I'm going to die so I don't go
there I want to ask you I want to ask
you a question that's unrelated I think
Sean put this here it's actually his
last question and I just read it and
it's the same question of I I have had
and we could see this now that um you
guys are public so Andrew's company is
publicly traded tiny.com you could slash
investors you can find all the good
stuff I think you guys even did your
annual meeting was a podcast which was
cool Sean has this question how the [__]
does meta lab make so much money
and that is a similar question that I
have
um it's astounding how how your your
services part of tiny does so well which
I think is it's I don't know where the
exact numbers you can clarify but it's
something in the range of Chinese making
50 or 60 million dollars a year
um with really healthy margins which is
just a very big agency
so yeah that's the question Andrew how
the [__] does meta lab make so much
money yeah I mean agencies can be
incredibly profitable and um they're
incredibly hard and I think that when
you do it for almost 20 years and you
have a niche so for example
um with matalab and we own you know the
numbers you're seeing are the Blended
collection of I think six or seven
different agencies
what's the public number
I
thought it was like 60 or 70.
yeah I don't know I mean this is one of
the downsides of being public right I
don't want to say some number and have
it be wrong and then sure you know
whatever but but you know anyone can go
look at the filings and see
um but for the group of those agencies
um you know they can be incredibly
profitable
um if you find a really really good
Niche and the nice thing with metal lab
is that
um you know we basically own product
design and building like MVPs for
startups and stuff in 2007 and we worked
at it for a really long time and so when
you have that reputation people will pay
up to get you right and there's really
not that many people that do it and do
it well and have the capabilities we do
so you can charge a premium uh and have
really healthy margins now that goes up
and down depending on what's going on in
the market depending on how much uh you
know how hard it is to hire a designer
and developer that kind of thing and the
problem with an agency is that it's the
most variable business in the world so
you know they're wonderful they produce
a lot of cash flow but for the last 20
years we we've actually been
aggressively diversifying away from
agencies and the agencies have just been
The Little Engine That Could they just
keep on growing and growing and growing
we didn't ever expect that metallab
would get to the scale it's at and um
you know it's been like an amazing
surprise Sean and I were just sitting
the exact same way yeah I know I had to
stop myself because I was like oh man
we're both like little
Shirley Temple
right when I saw that I was like I'll
let him go first but I know that there's
so many things here that we're good well
simple question does better lab get most
of its or like how many sales people
does metalab employ or people that like
their core thing is to go sell medalab
as a service to other people bring in
new accounts bring in business well so
we they don't really do a lot of
outbound
um so it's mostly mostly inbound demand
and again that's another reason why the
businesses the agencies in general have
been profitable like we've basically
focused on reputation and organic
whereas a lot of the big agencies and
people that have much lower margins so
like a typical agency will have 20
margins 15 margins even five percent
margins if it's poorly run often they
have to have a whole bunch of people out
there cold calling and selling we don't
have that problem to the same degree
people come to us and want to work with
us so I think the sales team is maybe
six or seven people or something like
that
um the whole company is about 150 or
something you have had a bunch of
agencies you've had meta-lab which is
product design was that I don't know
that's how I would classify it
um you've had a no code agency you have
um a Content agency you have like a
bunch of different agencies meta lab
seems to be like
the biggest winner by far like if it was
like there's like a power law right
inside your portfolio and and uh
and metal lab is bigger it's been around
for longer
um
is it because you started at the right
time is it because you were there as the
founder sweating it and grew it into
something big is it because that Niche
is better why is meta lab so much bigger
why have these other agencies not had
the same
sort of uh scale that meta lab was able
to achieve well we really only
um started based so here's what happens
so metalab was the Golden Goose that
provided all the cash flow that we used
to build tiny and buy all the other
businesses and to be honest we really
were kind of saying we don't want more
agencies
um you know we're happy to own that one
uh we'll hold it forever but that's not
an area we want to focus is that is that
beam is that is that division called
beam so here I'll just read it's called
beam I'll read here this is from your
2000 this is from your one of the
reports so founded in 2006 with zero
dollars invested never raised a cent of
equity
in 2021 it did 62 million in Revenue
with earnings of 21 million 20 uh sorry
that was 21 2022 it did 81 million with
about 20 million in in operating
earnings so those are the the public
numbers yeah
so um so anyways so we have this problem
so metal lab was getting to the point
where they could only do projects for
like 500 000 and so we had tons of
leaves coming and we had nowhere to send
them we would just say no
um and so we went out and we acquired a
small agency in Spain we spun up 80 20.
we kind of basically said look we've got
um we have a sawmill we've got all the
sawdust coming out of the Sawmill all
this demand we should go form this into
wood pellets and sell it and so we
basically created like a whole
constellation of smaller agencies to
service the leads from the big one and
then all of those agencies have kind of
moved out of the house now so they're
not reliant on metal lab leads anymore
to the same degree
um and we've had some amazing successes
while they're not as big most of those
we started for 25 Grand maybe or up up
to the biggest one we bought maybe for
500 Grand you know that business today
does two or three million dollars of
ebitda
um so there we've had some really good
win wins but I have this whole framework
of like one plus one equals a hundred
and you guys had Syed on yeah what'd you
think about that last week I guess I
loved it it was great and there's so
much about the way that he thinks we've
read all the same books
um a lot a lot was very similar and I
was nodding my head along but what he
did with wpbeginner where he goes hey
I've got this huge source of traffic
I've got all these users that want to be
told what plugins to use uh and then he
can go and buy these plugins that have a
customer acquisition problem they've
built a great product they're built by
developer they don't know how to Market
it they don't know how to Source
customers when you put those two things
together you're basically buying this
business on historical earnings but you
know you can 10x it tomorrow
um and to me that kind of reminds me of
what we've done in the agency space
we've said look we have you know 100
leads coming in every month that are you
know things we can't serve us we might
as well spin up all these agencies to
make a bunch of money from those two and
I love that model you told me that the
revenue and the profit I mean it's
almost 20 years old that the revenue
profit in some years it's been very
lumpy where like it went down a
significant amount the next year right
oh yeah it's it's a roller coat this is
the thing is everybody that looks at
these businesses goes wow these are
incredible I'd love to own an agency the
reality of an agency though is that it's
a whole bunch of people their hair is
always on fire they either have too
little work or too much work they've
either over hired or under hired and the
margins can swing around a lot if you're
not very disciplined so these are very
hard businesses they're not they're not
easy but they can be wonderful
businesses from a cash flow perspective
and certainly I mean Syed said as well
but if I was you know if I lost
everything and I didn't have my Twitter
subscribers I would probably go start an
agency like I think that is the easiest
way to make 500 Grand a year very very
simply that's changing with AI probably
but what Niche agency would you do if
you had to start over from scratch would
take away all your money and all your
all your audience well I would do design
just because that's what I know but
um you know that's that's my world right
like that's where I started
um but I don't know I don't know how
that evolves over time Sean are you
think about doing an agency me hell no
do you know anything about me I'm
looking to get rich the lazy way I'm not
trying to do the hard stuff but you can
do it this is what this is what drives
me crazy is you guys have look at Nick
Huber Nick Huber has 300 000 Twitter
followers and he basically said okay
um I get five different inquiries people
message me asking for SEO they ask me
for property appraisal they ask me for
web design and they asked me for no one
asked Nick for web design yeah yeah
super clear sure sure
in promotion Nick is one of my closest
friends he's doing an SEO agency I'm
like big do people ask you for SEO like
I didn't
but he's what he's doing what he's doing
is smart right so he's a human router so
he's got all these inquiries and then
he's writing them and so like what Sean
did so this whole framework of one plus
one equals a hundred like Sean what you
did with Shepard right you have this
business it perfectly aligns with you
you know the product all you have to do
is talk about it a bunch and it will do
well you haven't but that is a [__]
hard business that is an agency right
that's a recruiting agency which is a
brutal brutal comp kid business that's
just been all abstracted away from you
and you could do that you could abstract
away a digital agency if you guys want
to buy a piece to one of my digital
agencies and just promote the [__] out
of it I will happily uh do a deal with
you okay I will do that because you know
it's easy for me to tell people that
Shepard lets them hire talented people
for 10x lower price than in the United
States it's easy for me to tell people
that that they should go to support
Shepherd com and go do that that's not
hard right it's not hard for me to tell
people how much insane value there is
and how I use that for my businesses
easy stuff to do yeah and how would the
yeah good plug uh and I feel like I feel
like you guys are like uh you know when
I hear you say this it's like you're
looking at it and being like Oh a car
wash like I don't want to get my hands
like all wet and like I don't want to
scrub the cars and it's like dude you
just own the car wash yeah but you have
to make sure that the product is good
enough that you want to promote which
does involve brain power and worry sure
before before I'm sure Shepherd I tested
every product that does that on the
market I hired through each of them I
hired multiple people through Shepard
met with Marshall I was like okay here's
a deal that makes a lot of sense and
it's a it's at the right scale where it
works versus these like agencies from
zero I think are a lot harder but I will
say the shepherd experiment has been so
great that I can't wait to do the next
Shepherd because it is
it's the perfect thing right their
revenue doubles my income goes up
without the operational load customers
get a good service that they you know
that they they need and they want it
anyways that's that is like
so much easier than for example my econ
my econ business is like your agency
business like you know yesterday I'm
looking at the inventory forecast oh we
were way under then we were way over and
we're just constantly going to get this
wrong we have we need so many people to
do all the operations for this because
there's a physical product and you have
to do photo shoots and you have to do
everything to make this business work
um
and I'm like man this is hard mode
compared to you know the easy mode of
what the other side of things we're
doing
totally and that's the that's the thing
I think like to a man with a hammer
everything looks like a nail so it's
like you guys would probably both start
newsletters I'd start an agencies
whatever you know and is easy but it's
not the forever business like I have
this whole thing about um you wanna you
wanna before you launch your rocket you
need a launch pad build the launch pad
this is the launch pad business right it
just provides you the ability to go and
do the things you're really passionate
about could you explain the the one plus
one equals 100 did you say what that is
yeah so well basically it's the idea of
if you have an unfair Advantage so for
Syed it was he has WP beginner the blog
he has tons of people that are asking
hey what WordPress plugins should I use
and then if he buys a WordPress plugin
which he can buy for incredibly cheaply
he knows he can boost it so it's like a
guaranteed return to me it's like um you
know imagine if you own an airport and
there's like 10 000 people in the lobby
every day you know that you can sell
them hot dogs a hot dog stand is not a
good business but if you put a hot dog
stand in the middle of an airport I can
guarantee you're going to sell a lot of
hot dogs there's a story after the Syed
uh thing I I started reading about
Warren Buffett who I had I knew nothing
about and I've been texting Andrew I'm
like oh I get why you did this like this
sounds awesome you know of course it
sounds awesome when it's from the best
person who's ever done it but there's a
story in the late 60s when he was maybe
35 and he goes to a movie theater and he
goes boy it would be nice to own a
little bit of all these ticket sales of
all these people coming to this movie
this seems like a wonderful business and
then he goes you know there's this
company called Disney that's doing this
they even have a theme park let's go
check it out Charlie and so they
literally go to the theme park to like
figure out and they talk to like the the
attendance at the attendance at the
rides and they're like how many people
come in this thing and they're like
that's how they're doing their research
is they actually went went to the theme
park and then he ends up buying five
percent of Disney I think he paid four
million dollars so it was worth uh you
know not a lot of money back then and I
knocked out the park and then there's
another story about this guy he's like
yeah Warren Buffett was supposed to be
this wonderkin investor and we had all
heard about him but I was in New York
and I saw him walking around New York
like pacing counting his paces and I
asked him what he was doing he's like oh
we're going to invest in some type of
real estate deal and I wanted to figure
out how many Paces it made up of this
Square block so I can guess how many
like people are going in it was like
something crazy like that it was really
funny where he would actually test these
things he would look at the financials
and that was the most important thing
and then he would go like in real life
and actually test these things to see
like all right is this cool is this
legit what's this all about and or he
would like there's a story of him
literally knocking on the door at Geico
like hey can you get can someone talk to
me about this company tell me what you
guys do because the financials look
great and like it was pretty funny how
he did some of that stuff he was very
Hands-On yeah Buffett I'm so glad that
you're uh deep diving on Buffet it now
because it is it is the way I think
about it is it's business abstracted to
the ultimate degree you think about this
guy he's got 90 or 100 companies he's
got 375
000 employees and he sits on his ass
reading in Omaha every single day and I
just look at that and I go how do I how
do I do that and I don't know that
sitting on your ass reading all day is
the thing you want to do necessarily but
how do you take enough of Buffett do you
have the freedom to spend your time
however I I always heard people say that
so I was like oh I could read so I've
been reading like Thriller novels and
stuff like that I'm like I'm just like
buff it I'm just like Tom Clancy and
then I read it's biography and it's like
oh he's reading annual reports all day
[__] that I thought I could just sit at
home and read all day so I've been
reading like history books I'm like I'm
just like buff it and then I read this
book on him and I'm like oh he's reading
like textbooks like it's way different
yeah Chris when Chris and I started tiny
uh maybe eight or nine years ago we were
like oh we were reading all the Buffett
books and we're like okay this is what
we're gonna do we're just gonna read
annual reports all day we print out all
these annual reports and I think we
lasted like four hours
it's so boring and it's these guys are
like they're they're so all they want to
do is read right like Charlie Munger he
just reads all day I think Buffett said
500 pages a day that he would read it's
crazy it's insane that's a book a day a
500 a day uh it's so boring I like I
also try to do that when I went and
looked at the edible reports and I'm
like
they're using the same words over and
over again I don't even know what these
words mean uh it's challenging uh you
have some interesting topics on here I
want to do them so
um what is the give me these two cool
businesses so cool business number one
no story lost what is that yeah so this
is really cool so have you guys heard of
the business story worth yeah I'm a big
fan of it
yeah it's super smart started by this
guy Nick Baum he him and I worked out of
the same office when he was starting it
so he was he he I was one of his first
customers I love him yeah he's awesome
he's living living it up on I think he's
on Maui right now just living there and
living the dream but basically um you
buy it for like your parents or your
grandparents your siblings or whatever
uh I think it's like 99 bucks and all it
does is it just sends like a drip
campaign of questions and so it'll be
like hey like tell me about your
childhood uh what was a moment where you
struggled in a job who is your first
boss all these things that you've always
been curious to know about your family
and you can choose all the questions or
whatever and then at the end of the year
it compiles it into a book that you can
then print and share with your family or
whatever and I thought like wow this is
an amazing idea so I go and I spend 200
bucks I buy it for my parents and of
course my parents fill it out for like
three weeks and then they just stop and
I talked to my dad and he's like well
it's a lot of writing you know a lot of
time and so I I was a little annoyed but
I was like whatever
and then I met this guy actually locally
here in Vancouver and he has this
business called No story lost and it's
like the VIP version of story worth and
so what they do is you just say okay Dad
look we're going to schedule like three
zooms you're just gonna talk to these
people and they basically have like
biographers they interview your parents
or your siblings or whatever and then
they actually write a proper biography
of them so I'm about to get this book
um professionally written book about my
Dad's life and I'm so excited to read it
and my dad was just so much happier
because he didn't he just had to talk
and like my dad loves to talk so yeah
it's a really neat little business I
think it's like two grand or something
versus 200. do you know how big the
biggest business is I don't I don't
think it's very big wait you met this
guy he has a cool business and you
didn't strap him down and waterboard him
until he told you his annual revenue I
actually I invest I think I invested 25k
in it
um on basically like no questions asked
give him 25k I think it's doing like
maybe
a million or something but I think their
big problem is customer acquisition so
one plus one equals a hundred here I am
talk about it maybe blow this up and you
don't need that many people to do it in
order for it to do very well but I think
their problem is that so Nick makes a
[__] ton of money I think off story
worth you think so um because oh because
it's automated right you don't need any
employees you basically build it once
and it and then you just Market it
um whereas this you got to actually have
a writer work with every single person
that buys it so I think it's a much
harder business model but as a customer
I think it's a really awesome idea I
feel like these are the businesses that
AI is gonna like just really help all
their margins because
you can have an AI biographer like an
antibiographer is like a very good use
case for these llms where they can ask
questions that they know will poke and
prod they can take your responses and
ask follow-ups and they can summarize
all the audio that's coming in and
transcribe it for so so that the writer
then can come in take the source
material and like you could cut the
writer's work down by something probably
like 50 to 80 percent did you guys see
the book or the business called um it
was called book in a box then it was
called scribe and Sean was a customer of
them but basically uh my friend Tucker
Max started it and he hired a CEO to run
it and basically you would talk to
someone for I don't even remember how
long and you pay 30 or 40 or 50 Grand
the prices have gone up throughout the
years and they write a book for you and
it's mostly business people who want to
write a book and eventually like it's
paid speaking in Consulting gigs but I
thought it was doing great and all of a
sudden out of nowhere not only did go
bankrupt but like there was like
petitions from the authors who were who
worked for the company as as uh
contractors are like revolting and like
it's caused a lot of controversy but
they owe you Sean a book right you paid
them like tens of thousands of dollars
and you just forgot about it or you
bailed on it yeah it was like you know I
bought I paid I was like oh yeah I want
to write a book great these people help
you write a book they'll you know I'm a
guy with more ideas than time this will
save me time fantastic let's let's try
this and it's the same sort of idea like
they you have the book idea the concepts
they hop on the phone with you they help
you flush it out it's like great I want
to collaborator with that and then as
you're fleshing it out you're basically
you can talk and they're taking all the
notes and then they'll draft in your you
know in the voice that you want and you
edit right and I was like oh that seems
like a good idea but I was so busy like
we we started the milk road I was like
okay I'm if I'm operating a business I
have to like do this well and so I
paused it and not not just an iposite we
have like five friends who all bought
books and then pause them for various
reasons nailed not bailed in our mind
the door was always open
and uh and yeah the door's still open I
guess we just have to pay a little more
money to get it finished now if we want
to well you know
um I think I can say this because they
tweeted it but enduring Ventures uh
Xavier and sieva they bought it yes just
uh yeah today I wasn't is that public
yeah he tweeted it like he tweeted it
out I've heard I'd heard about that but
I wasn't sure if he was going to do it
or not I don't know what's going on
behind the scenes but for a company to
go bankrupt that quickly without like
any type of signs I wonder if
something's going on
um but I I it seems like it might be a
headache but maybe it won't be we'll see
yeah I actually did it too like years
ago I was thinking about I'm working on
a book actually right now I ended up not
doing it with scribe but um I tried it
and I just found that it's great I think
if you want to write like a a corporate
handbook that you can hand out to like
your employees or something like that
like a Cheesy business book but if you
actually want to write something like
really really serious and legit I think
it's a bit hard I know David Goggins is
like their their hit he's their hit but
I think it's just hard again for the
reasons we talked about with no story
lost how do you guarantee quality when
you have that much demand and stuff like
I think you'd have to move up Market
I've been waiting for you to mention
that you have doing the book thing
because I wasn't sure if it was public
or not Sean you should read his first
chapter I read the whole thing normally
people ask me to prove stuff and I'm
like I don't want to and then I started
reading his and I was like okay I'm
actually into this it's pretty good it's
been quite good yeah I can't wait I
think it's gonna be amazing oh thanks
dude how far yeah I'll share it with you
I just sent the publisher my rough draft
it's still I'd say it's still in the
phase where like I'm embarrassed by it
um but I know that's the important step
to making it amazing
um so yeah I think it'll come in 2024.
what's your motivation why write a book
honestly kind of to like muddle through
like a there's a lot of lessons that I
haven't read in other books around
um business and stuff that we've learned
so it's kind of the story of building
tiny but also just to kind of muddle
through the exact thing we were talking
about before about how everybody wants
more
um you know it's never enough they're
always trying to upgrade they're always
trying to get bigger they're always
trying to do the next thing and play the
status game or you know comes from
childhood trauma or you know something
else and so for me it's been about
pulling that string for myself so it's
been a bit of kind of personal
exploration and stuff
um it's been it's been fun I've really
enjoyed it it's probably the thing I've
enjoyed most over the last couple years
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most crms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better do you want
to talk about some of these other
companies I know you have routines on
here you have I don't even know how to
pronounce this one it looks like a
Hawaiian name yeah let me let me Buzz
through both
um so routines is really smart so you
know when you listen to Tim Ferriss
interview
um it's like two hours and sometimes
you're just like look dude like look
doctor you know gut microbiome doctor
just tell me what you do what do you do
what do I take what do I buy uh and I
actually was talking to Tim Ferriss
about this and I was like dude you've
got to add like a little segment at the
end where you just say here's the books
here's the one book recommendation
here's one product recommendation here's
one habit recommendation from each guest
he never did it too bad
um but that's the Jew that's the stuff
that I ask people when I'm one-on-one
with them and so my friend Hamza who I
think you know too Sam yeah I use this
agency it's good Tampa yeah there are
agencies called Tamba t-a-m-b-a uh they
do really good work but um so he created
this site called routines so it's
routines.club is the URL and what it
does is it basically runs you through
the day of successful people and so they
do like huberman Tim Ferriss Peter attia
uh they actually just did one on Andrew
Wilkinson yeah yeah and and basically
breaks down my entire day from start to
finish and it's all these things that I
wouldn't even think to share it's like
you know how do I organize my email how
do I um you know what supplements do I
take in the morning your shower and skin
routine is huge right shower and skin
all these random things what's really
funny is he's used he's used um uh
mid-journey or whatever to generate
images for all the things so it's this
like terrifying hey you look like
first picture I mean this is just a plus
I mean mid-journey is like you know the
world's greatest wingman here second
picture now you're you I feel like this
is like these are two different people
these are not the same person uh but
that's you know one of those challenges
so you wake up six to eight a.m all
right big window
um
drinkable it's depending on if my kids
wake me take a big glass of water with
electrolytes if it's sunny you make air
press coffee nice nice plug
um
if it's overcast you use retimer what's
retimer it's like these little goggles
that you wear and they blast your eyes
with uh bright light they're to help you
kind of wake up in the morning like if
it's not sunny out you know how huberman
is like go outside and see bright lights
oh this is great you don't have to go
outside yeah so you don't have to go
outside I'm looking anyway there's like
if you read through it it'll take like
20 minutes because there's so many
freaking things dude you take you take
10 supplements uh yeah like on and off
depending on what they are well here's
you have a good morning routine by the
way was it coffee you snort coke uh yeah
I shoot up I shoot heroin right between
my toes and it actually says where which
foot to do it in
um but but so here's what's cool about
this business is people want to share
this stuff right it's like a very
infinitely shareable like listicle of
like here's this person's routine or
whatever but throughout it if you look
at the huberman one for example he
recommends ag-1 he recommends cold
plunges supplements it's all affiliate
Revenue yeah and so it's just like one
of these amazing build the content ones
update it occasionally focused on SEO
make like thirty thousand dollars a
month plus of um affiliate it's just a
perfect we talked about earlier like the
launch pad business it's not the sexy
business it's the launch pad this is
cool I like this uh I like this example
do the Maui Nui one what is that so this
one is really I I thought this was super
goofy uh when I heard about it and so
basically me and my girlfriend we were
visiting Maui
um and huberman was like oh you should
meet this guy
um Jake who runs Maui Nui and so this
guy picks me up in this like ramshackle
truck he looks like a Navy SEAL he's
like the super jacked guy Ai and he
starts telling me he drives us into this
huge Ranch that they have and he starts
telling me about the business and
basically
um there's these deer called access deer
and they're from Asia I have a on my
Ranch yeah some Hawaiian royalty brought
them to Hawaii to hunt like 150 years
ago and because they had no natural
Predators they're just an invasive
species they're like rats they're like
everywhere and it's actually an
environmental problem so they're like a
pest they actually destroy the ecosystem
and so the government literally flies
helicopters and takes like you know
machine guns and just guns these things
down that's their current solution to
this and so
Jake was like hey we could this is great
meat a lot of native Hawaiians hunt the
meat and it's super healthy and
delicious they sell it locally but the
FDA doesn't let you sell meat uh
commercially and so he basically spent
the last seven years getting approval to
actually hunt and sell this meat and
it's this like super complex problem so
there's this interesting moat in the
business it's going to take someone else
like seven to ten years to compete and
basically what they do is they have a
bunch of professional Hunters go with
sniper rifles and they in the middle of
the night they just shoot these deer in
the head right and it has to be the FDA
is like it has to be in the head like so
imagine this you're a deer you get to
live this awesome life you are eating
organic food you're running all over
Hawaii and then one day in your sleep
you just boom you're dead right and so I
was like okay this is really fascinating
uh so huberman Tim Ferriss attia they
all invested too
um and here's what's crazy about the
meat so not only is it like the most
ethical meat you could possibly have
because it's like a past these deer like
killed super ethically and stuff but
they've tested it and it has crazy micro
nutrient content so a piece of salmon is
like 14 protein this is 20 protein like
beef is like nine percent it's good for
the environment the animals live natural
lives and then one day Boom headshot
gone and so if you're like uh you know
you're not eating meat for ethical
reasons or for health reasons this is
like an incredible business and so these
guys sell like I think like 10 20
million dollars a year of pepperoni
sticks and all this stuff so anyway go
check it out Maui I'm ordering this
stuff did you invest in this I did yeah
can you tell I mean I'm giving you the
full your sales pitches are good um Sam
how did you you said you have these uh
these same deer on your Ranch randomly
in Texas he just told this story about
like how this Japanese royalty brought
it to Hawaii and it's like this whole
special thing you're like yeah I got I
got
what are you talking about well so it's
just I I don't know anything about
animals or hunting but out in my farm
you can only hunt normal deer I think
for two or three months out of the year
but we have this thing called Axis deer
I don't know if access deer is like a
category of animal or what no I'm
looking at it looks the same they're
basically deers with spots on them and
sometimes they have like tall ears or uh
and so they kind of look different but
they're called Axis deer they have spots
and they're all over Texas I don't know
if it's like the same thing
um or if it's like a category of animal
but yeah we have them in Texas I love
how this random guy in Hawaii just told
a fascinating story I got it guys
they're rats that are everywhere
actually that's like you know totally
like they just needed to get this like
waste product off their hands or like
you know this thing's got 20 protein 80
look and 100 power of oil I'm buying
this I love this man this is great like
yeah and I'll be like oh you need an
access deer I got a guy
you know like every everyone like 20
years ago was really into like drinking
milk right like got milk and then it was
almond milk then it was oat milk you
guys are gonna love my next business
it's rat milk are you serious no I could
have I'm gonna order some of this beef
I'm uh so like over the last two weeks
I've gotten a little soft you know I had
a little injury so I didn't work out
like religiously over the last two weeks
and I've been eating a lot of ice cream
because it's hot so for the next 30 days
Sean you should try and join this with
me I'm only gonna eat meats and or uh
planted animals I gotta get I gotta get
back to basic planted animals oh yeah
that's good I like the way you branded
that that's nice plants and animals
that's for the next 30 days I gotta get
my action together because I've been
eating too much ice cream but I'm gonna
order this stuff uh I'm gonna order it
this actually looks great is this a fun
business to run it looks fun to run but
it might be a headache you gotta ship
this [__] all the way from Hawaii I
think it's super complicated I think
they can charge a premium because I
think they're the only people that are
FDA approved to sell it and you know
they have the story and the brand and
the investors and stuff but it's a hard
business for that same reason right I
mean there's a lot of people there's a
lot of hunters
um on the Hawaiian islands that want the
jobs and stuff but logistically you know
these guys are basically going on these
like uh hikes in the middle of the night
to go and do these like you know they're
sniping deer and then they have to
shoulder carry them back to the truck
and then they've got this whole facility
there to process them and stuff isn't
the problem isn't the problem with this
so I I've got a lot of like I've got a
bunch of the funny thing about Austin is
it's full of like crazy Health people
like like you know you don't even know
like are they actually insane or are
they being serious like you know they're
afraid of Wi-Fi but every once in a
while some of these guys will say
something that's like really interesting
and like turns out they're right and one
of them being is like do you know
butcher box butcher boxes bootstrapped
and I think it does like two or three
hundred million dollars in Revenue but
my health nut friends hate it they talk
trash about it they're like this is the
war first you should never consume that
meat these guys will also say like Whole
Foods they don't even touch Whole Foods
Chicken they're like you can't it's
Gotta like if it's not it doesn't look a
certain way I don't touch it you're
hanging out with Justin mares too much I
didn't want to name names I don't know
if Justin if if Justin has said that
explicitly but yeah they're in the same
Circle it just sounds like something
that Justin would say for he's probably
correct though he's probably but that's
my thing it's these guys I'll be like
all right but are you being like a
conspiracy or are you being like
truthful and they're like this one's a
little closer to conspiracy but then
with like the meat stuff like this is
close to truthful but the problem with
this business I would think is the
bigger it gets the worse it gets right
well I think when I talk to him about
scaling and stuff he was like look
there's a lot of Hawaiian Islands
there's a lot of deer is there though I
think is it yeah oh yeah
well there's six or seven of them or
whatever right and they they basically
they do this on a tiny amount of land as
it is right now so I think they can't
really I think you're thinking about the
signal it's not a business investment
there might be a business here this is a
Larry Ellison investment this is a this
is some rich people do which is as you
make money you start investing just in
things that are interesting you start
you start investing in dinner party
conversations it's like I can't have my
whole portfolio of like healthcare SAS
like even if that's where you know like
the most money is made I need to invest
in things that are interesting to me
that are cool people that I want to hang
out with that do businesses that are
worth talking about in life and there's
like there's like a positive EV
associated with that that people don't
really understand until you you start
doing it and then you're like oh this is
nice you just gotta keep the check small
and do a bunch of these and so you have
this portfolio of like interesting this
one day I think I I would say I would
say you're wrong
um so
uh so so imagine like you're saying the
same thing about athletic greens right
okay so I come to you and I'm like hey
guys there's like these these guys
they're like a vitamin but it's powder
and you're like that's the stupidest
thing I've ever heard what makes
athletic greens amazing amazing is that
they spent the last 15 years building
relationships with all the most
influential Health people in the world
so it's one plus one equals a hundred
right they have Tim Ferriss they have
all these people who not only they buy
ads with but they also have all these
people owning equity in the business so
a million different competitors can come
out but if in your brain the winner is
ag-1 because that's what you've heard
and all the people that you respect do
you will do it and you will pay a
premium right yeah but that's different
like vitamins were a thing uh vitamins
were a thing greens green smoothies
people understood oh I should eat my
vegetables that's been around forever I
don't know how many people are like oh
man the protein content on my salmon is
too low I need to eat deer I need to eat
this bread it's bigger than you think
it's bigger than you know what I'm
looking for a deer that was shot in the
head that's what I know but there's a
huge there's a huge audience though for
people who go I want ethically sources I
do that right that's why I don't like
buying a lot of speech is because I I
don't like how they kill cows Sean you
actually kind of turned me on to that uh
about like about the treatment of cows
well I think this is very hypocritical I
think you know anybody who's like
ethically sourced meat it's like uh you
know like yeah if somebody's like I
ethically killed your dog or I ethically
killed your your brother it's like you
know no but there's a big difference
well it's not necessarily killing it's
raising I think and then killing and
then correct think about it think about
it correct think about it this way so
there's there's a broad spectrum right
so you think about like industrialized
meat is like concentration camps for
animals right they're literally in these
pens and they're fed this horrible stuff
and they have these miserable lives I
don't feel good about eating that do I
feel good about eating an animal who
lived a great life and then got sniper
rifled in the head yeah I feel fine I
actually feel fine there's definitely a
spectrum just to be clear though this is
still in the murdering for our pleasure
uh for our mouth Pleasures part of the
spectrum and there's a there's a lot
more part of the spectrum that you go to
if you chose to I'm I'm uh I'm totally a
bit of a hypocrite on this as in I do
eat meat so I'm not like I'm not like a
vegan telling you this but at least I
don't lie to myself and tell myself that
oh man I'm doing so such a good thing
morally here by uh a Kill by killing
them the best way the nice way yeah you
it's like it's like you might drive an
electric car and it's better than
driving a gas car but you're still
producing tons of toxic chemicals
because we made the batteries and stuff
it's just a little bit better yeah
that's right I agree with you though I
do think like in 100 years we'll look
back at eating meat and be a little
shocked yeah 100
um that's my my opinion Sean would you
would you if we went somewhere would you
like for example for Thanksgiving did I
tell you for Thanksgiving we killed our
own turkey no you didn't tell me that
how was that uh yeah and so would you do
that
no
wow okay not that I wouldn't do it would
I be excited am I excited to go do that
no would I do it if that's the thing we
wanted to do sure I'm not like anti the
whole experience but uh I'm not like
pumped about that nor would I like see
that experience out also turkey
massively overrated it sucks separate
issue and by the way killing it and
eating it it did not taste good at all
the fake [__] like the Butterball
turkeys taste way better and turkey is a
is a horrible meat but yeah I agree
um what do we want to wrap up with one
or two more things yeah let's do uh well
you have a question for Sam I think
that's an interesting one why don't you
do that one Andrew yeah I was curious so
Sam like I look at Hampton Hampton is a
business I mean I've said this to you
privately but Hampton is the business
that I've thought about starting for 10
years so I joined something called
entrepreneurs organization uh 15 years
ago and I was like this is a very very
good business every member of EO pays
five thousand dollars and there's all
these local chapters they self-organize
basically and these guys just must be
making an absolute killing and you have
this total lock-in because once you like
your Forum group you have these like
core core groups like you do at Hampton
or whatever people don't want to leave
they're locked in they pay their five
thousand dollars a year or whatever it
is they go to events Etc and so I for
years have been like someone needs to
start the new EO and you have and so I
look at it and I I go freak damn I wish
I owned that business
um what are the things though like just
like you guys being like Oh my God like
you know these agencies Andrew Owens are
the best businesses ever what are the on
the flip side what are the things that
we we should know about Hampton that are
make it hard to run or surprise you
about running so the thing about Hampton
so Andrew joined and Sean John has been
like messaging like maybe I should join
and I'm like Andrew wanted to he's like
yeah just take my money and just let me
join I'm like no no no you have to get
interviewed I just want a little VIP
treatment I just want a little past line
it's like we've not done it to go to a
friend's restaurant and you just get
treated as a normal Patron
how does it feel good it's not the same
I agree that feels a little bad wouldn't
you think well because we have to have
we have to indoctrinate people we have
to like get them into the values of the
system we have to like teach them how to
be a good Community member so the thing
about Hampton is that in terms of like
the physics behind it this is going to
be a massive company I think
uh like there's I always tell our team
there's nothing holding us back like
there's like very little like outside
factors that are gonna ruin it but the
number one thing that sucks about it and
that we we 100 can screw it up and it
can go to zero is if you start letting
in too many people too quickly so you
cannot scale it like crazy fast
um I think you can scale it fast but I
think you can't scale it like you could
a software you're not just throwing
bodies into it and so we have to be
super thoughtful about it about who we
let in and why another thing is is that
the feedback loop is fairly short so
people in Hampton have monthly meetings
and then now we have Retreats that
people go on once a year or twice a year
so we don't get feedback that quickly
and in order to like I can't just like
make an assumption or I can't like have
like an MVP of a retreat because
someone's flying across the country to
go to a thing so it has to be good right
away and that's very stressful that I
can't like just like you know if I own
like a Shopify store I can't just throw
up a product up there and have someone
buy it and then just return the money
and be like sorry it'll come soon or
this sucks maybe but it'll improve with
tech
um so that's scary about not having MVPs
but you it the the thing about Community
is once you screw it up I don't think
you can fix it and so it seems like it's
high stakes all the time and so that's
why we're trying to be meticulous about
growing slowly
um I don't know Andrew what am I missing
you've kind of like no I think you're
right I it's interesting the thing that
made me leave EO
um so the chapter
um the guy who ran the chapter super
nice guy like amazing I love the guy but
he let in a couple people who I really
really didn't like and I found myself
dreading going to some of the events and
just kind of just sketchy people right
like people that ran a bit dicey
businesses and gave me bad vibes and
stuff and that was actually the thing
that caused me to leave EO and do my own
forums so I now have four forums that I
just managed myself
um but I I don't think most people are
like me I think most people will stick
with it but you do really have to be
thoughtful about who you let in and I I
think the hardest part and I've had this
experience I've ran a lot of forums over
the last 15 years and been in a lot of
forums if there's someone who's toxic
the cancer has to be cut out but that is
an incredibly awkward conversation and
it can really piss people off obviously
and we've fired a punch but we've kicked
people out if they like talk about
confidential stuff publicly but um also
another thing about this these
businesses the thing about EO YPO Visage
do you guys know vistage I think I
mentioned them they sold for like 1.5
billion recently they're already doing
like half a billion in Revenue dude they
last so long so YPO EO and Visage I
think all were either started in the 50s
or the 60s and so the cool thing about
these companies is if you nail it right
you can have it for 50 or 100 years and
so that's why I'm really fascinated by
these types of companies because there's
zero technological or there's zero Tech
like Tech everything can change with AI
it will have zero hope I think how does
how does it feel to be sitting on a
winner like does it did you feel the
same way with the hustle does this feel
different yeah I I felt like the hustle
like with with Hampton I'm like well
there's a clear path to get to 100
million dollars you just got to give it
10 years if you want uh in Revenue like
I just have to like it's just a Time
Horizon thing you just gotta sit and
wait and you have to work but you have
to wait whereas with the hustle it felt
a little bit more like we were making
we are innovating in a very small space
where I'm like I don't know if the math
shows that this will work it might it
might not but I'm we're still learning
with this business I'm like no it's 100
gonna work the only thing that screws it
up is ourselves that's why I say there's
no like physics allows this to work
perfectly you also have an unfair
Advantage right I think that if you I
mean I guess you launched Hampton
privately you didn't promote it but now
that you did it's so unfair now that you
have talked about it you have like you
have free customer acquisition yes
you you almost have 50 million dollars a
year versus a free marketing by going on
podcasts on this podcast and other
podcasts you're on and just talking
about Hampton and then your brand value
as a person being associated with it it
is that one plus one equals 100 yes and
right now we've had five or six or seven
thousand people I forget apply and so
that makes it like the easiest thing
ever but if you look at on deck on Deck
had that as well and they totally [__]
it up they [__] it up because they
they treated it like a tech company
where they weren't thoughtful and enough
and they try to just scale and that is
my fear of like getting greedy and
growing too quickly well they raised
they raised Ventures why would you raise
Venture it's like this is a business
that pays for it's got you have negative
cash conversion cycle right people
pre-pay you for services delivered over
a year and like it's insane yeah so it's
like a great business I think it's going
to be like I don't think we'll ever sell
it but I think it could be like a they
can be billion dollar companies I think
um so it feels good well tiny if you
ever decide to sell it tiny bro I I or
if you ever want to take money off the
table I think I hopefully it'll be big
enough that we'll be buying you I I mean
no but and seriously when I was looking
the reason Andrew even though we're
friends I really admire you because when
I people have been asked to invest and
I'm like no dude this is my meta lab
baby like this could like this is what I
love I don't ever want to sell it but it
might make a [__] ton of profit and we
can just use that profit to buy stuff
that kind of uh supplements it
um and I don't want to take any money
because I don't want to have to feel
guilty about doing that we're gonna I'm
gonna uh be on a helicopter and it'll
land on Sam's yacht and then I'll I'll
get there and he'll be like oh what's
your market cap and I'll be like oh like
five billion and he'll be like oh
Hampton's 25 billion that's cute no I
don't know I remember when we hit five
those are things the come-up is always
the most I got a lot of advice for you
earlier
I think it's cool but it it feels like I
haven't talked about it publicly too
much is because this is the first time
where I'm like I'm just gonna shut the
[__] up and just be quiet and just keep
on going
um because it's working nicely I think
it's actually quite hard to replicate
though you have to have an audience it
was quite hard to like get the uh early
customers but yeah it feels good well
it's it you're reading the right book
right like reading the Buffett stuff and
moats because that I think that's like
the ultimate like people think investing
is numbers there's a little bit of that
there's napkin math but at the end of
the day it's like assessing like what is
the mo what's the competitive advantage
and you just have such a crazy
competitive advantage in terms of
customer acquisition and then also
customer life and Sean I know that
you're exploring this business even
before I don't even think you told me so
it's the big learning it's a logistical
nightmare so not nightmare but it's very
challenging like in like imagine let's
say we have 10 000 members and we're
doing all these Retreats that's
basically a retreat a day
you know what I mean like yeah it's
quite challenging logistically what we
need to do is go and hire a bunch of
McKinsey nerds and it's like here's how
we do it by hand automate it uh but I
don't I don't agree with that I think um
so what EO does is they've outsourced
everything so when you EO has chapters
there's a Vancouver chapter for example
uh all the members pay their dues and
then there's a chapter head and they are
managing that whole thing and then when
they have Retreats they're just told hey
um you know the budget typically is this
you guys all self-organize one person
from The Forum is responsible for
managing it here's the handbook on doing
it and they just kind of do it
themselves so I think there may be
there's a better way to do it but I
don't think you have to scale up
headcount legit no I don't think you do
either but you still have thousands of
people flying places and you want to
make sure that the experience is optimal
so there's still some quality control
are you gonna do like a massive
conference like a super Conference of
all the people in Hampton with like
insane speakers and stuff or is that
just too much Logistics yeah we want to
yeah I'm just trying to figure out how
to do it Andrew what is this uh profit
first methodology that's that book that
you like I love this so yeah one of the
guys
um one of the CEOs is actually the CEO
of beam
um he sent me this book and
um I love the idea so basically um you
know there's this concept of like if you
eat your food on a smaller plate you're
gonna eat less you guys know about that
um so basically what you do it's very
simple let's say that you earn a hundred
dollars in your business and you want to
have a 50 profit margin you just take
the day the hundred dollars comes in you
take fifty dollars and you put it in a
bank account that you can't see and
that's it you just put it away and so
then you and your team are left with
fifty dollars to run the business and
you know you might have to adjust the
number and figure out what's sustainable
but what I learned running
um all my digital businesses was that we
had businesses with 90 net profit
margins and if you had looked at that
business and said okay well it's this
kind of business it should have twenty
percent profit margins we easily could
have run it that way but because Chris
and I were incentivized we own the whole
business we paid a lot of attention to
the p l and what was possible we would
try and run it at the maximum profit and
so this basically allows you to achieve
the same thing psychologically as the
smaller plate You're just showing you're
basically budgeting for fifty percent
profit and you're saying figure that
cause issues with your CEO of the
company
but we don't do it this isn't something
that we do this is something that we've
sent out to all of our CEOs as like hey
this is really interesting this might be
something you might want to do but I
think it works better for small
businesses I know a lot of people who
um they talk to me and they're like oh
you know I have an agency too but we
just can't figure out how to make it run
at X margins and I'm I kind of go like
rip the Band-Aid right if you want to
make 30 profit margins take thirty
dollars of every hundred dollars that
comes in you move it to another bank
that's what you told me to do and I've
not been comfortable with it yet
dude you yeah don't even get me started
[Music]
Sam Sam and I have had like Tech
screaming matches me just being like
dude you have to Dividend your money out
because my whole thing is um you don't
want to leave excess cash burning a hole
in the CEO's Pockets or making them
complacent so let's say you own a
business that has a payroll of five
hundred thousand dollars a month a lot
of people will leave like 20 million
dollars in that business and I think
that just lets the CEO feel relaxed I
like them to basically have a month two
months of cash but you're spending
you're spending cash that you haven't
earned yet well sometimes but if if
that's the situation and they need more
then they just say hey shareholders uh
send me some of that money back but you
say I'm the bank so for example in tiny
tiny the holding company above is the
bank and we basically say look keep your
money with us and um if you guys hit a
snag and you need a little bit of extra
money for payroll or r d or whatever
we'll send that right down in you know
12 hours
so for prepaid meta customers which you
I don't actually think you do prepay but
let's say you did let's say someone
prepaid for a project that will take a
year and it's a hundred grand and you
get that up front you're happy or you're
willing to spend that 100 Grand before
the years up and the service has been
fully delivered well not always but I
think if you can model it and like so
for example the argument we were having
so someone pays ten thousand dollars for
a year of service in Hampton and so you
guys have all this cash sitting in the
bank the thing is you guys have new
members constantly streaming in so you
have ten thousand dollars flowing in x
times a day you have very predictable
cash flow from my perspective I would
basically just say all right what's your
what's your uh expected margin and I
just take that and dividend it out
immediately
um and I and again it's trying to create
a feeling of always always paying
attention to the bank account always
paying attention to the balance sheet
and the p l and I just think that when
you have a year of cash just sitting
there I think you your CEO will
naturally be like oh we could do this
you know we could go do a super
conference and spend 10 million dollars
on it or
um you know what it's okay we didn't uh
do that great this month because you
know we've got all this money in the
bank I think psychologically you want
everyone eating from a smaller place and
when you say dividend out what
percentage is Andrew Wilkinson taking
home to buy a home in cars and live
versus dividend out to reinvest into
your own stuff
I had like a well so it's different now
that we're public what I used to do is I
would get I owned 80 percent of um of
beam basically and I would get so I'd
get 80 of those dividends those would go
to my holding company I would buy stocks
or invest my general framework for this
though is I want to spend five percent
of what I earn at most and so whatever
that number is if you're in you know 10
million dollars a year 500 Grand a year
is just living doing whatever and
everything else should get invested so
you live on five percent of your of your
income and the rest goes to Tiny or
whatever is the setup for your holding
company or is Tiny considered your
holding company tiny is my well so I
have a personal holding company where I
have my personal assets but you know 90
plus percent of my net worth isn't tiny
hmm
so and has it always been five percent
so when you're earning a million dollars
a year when you're earning a million
dollars a year were you only spending
fifty thousand
no I was well I wasn't spending a ton
but I was what I was doing is starting a
lot of businesses I would I would say
maybe it was 20 or 30 back then but over
time it's come down to about five
percent or less and it's been there for
probably 10 years
um but um but yeah one of the things I
see that a lot of people do that's
really quite stupid is they don't let
themselves live it up so they'll own
this amazing cash flowing business and
they don't let themselves you know go by
the beautiful house go buy the great car
and so they end up acting in this way
where they go well I've got to sell my
company I've got to have an exit and I
have I have had friends where it's like
dude the exit was right in your bank
account you know you could have just
dividended the money out to yourself and
then you wouldn't have had this really
stressful horrible experience with
private equity and been through all that
stuff
um so I'm a big advocate of like living
it up living a nice life you know don't
go crazy and buy Faberge eggs but like
buy a nice car in a nice house and
whatever and then just invest everything
what percentage of your income do you
spend Sean uh I don't know I don't even
think about like that
um is that like is that are you allergic
to that or or would you I'm not allergic
to it but it's it's like you said like
you know uh I would say my income has
10x and my spending has 2x so as long as
that ratio stays about right that's fine
yeah I don't really look at the
percentage versus versus earnings so
much as like
you know before I guess like at the
beginning when the earnings were lower
right like for a long time I was
basically earning like between I don't
know
like in my 20s I was making like 120 to
160k a year roughly uh for a bunch of my
20s and you know during that time I
don't know I was probably I was living
in San Francisco paying California taxes
like you know I was probably spending uh
if you include taxes you know I was
spending the bulk of my money I wasn't
really saving that much probably saving
20 of my money 30 I don't know something
like that
um
and you know the uh Tim Ferriss said
this thing on this podcast I really
liked he goes
um unless Something's Gonna Make a [__]
ton of money give it away for free I
think that's a great rule in business
and content and a great room for
creators like us I think the uh which is
partly why I don't like your your
Twitter experiment although I understand
the reasons why you do it
um I think there's the same thing for
sort of like you know where do you put
your mental energy around finances it's
like
either needs to make a lot of money or
save a lot of money or I'm just gonna
like not pay I'm gonna give it zero
budget mentally
um because otherwise I'm just using my
mental Budget on too many things I'm
just not gonna think I don't want to
think about things unless it's like a a
large swing so for most of most of my
20s I was just trying to figure out how
do you make way more money like I'm not
trying to go from 20 savings rate to 30
savings rate it's like how do I 10x my
income that was like the first you know
like it's all I was thinking about it
took me a long time but like
that paid off because once you do that
you don't you're you're so glad you're
never worried about the the smaller
thing yeah ramit Sethi has a great book
called I will teach you to be great and
he talks a lot about that right people
obsess over like oh you know I used to
spend six bucks on a Frappuccino and now
I just buy a black coffee and save three
bucks and it's like you're so much
better off focusing on the macro you
know your mortgage all those sorts of
big expenses and then just focusing on
making way more money to the point where
it really doesn't matter he goes don't
focus on three dollar problems like a
cup of coffee focus on thirty thousand
dollar problems like getting a raise
notice this with hiring too like you
hire somebody and
um I'm negotiating like a 5k or 10K
salary difference and I'm like okay
um so you know you're this basically
like an 800 a month gross uh difference
net to them after taxes is gonna be like
500 a month difference okay fair enough
not saying that that's nothing but like
the percentage of their concern around
that difference versus like the role who
I am what they're going to learn from
this like how like they don't really
think about how do I use this
opportunity to be able to make 10 times
more money in the future or or better
what are the terms on their stock
options how are they struck what's the
valuation is it reasonable yeah or like
yeah what's mine what is my incentive if
I could do a great job what does a great
job even look like here and then how
much is that worth to you and can I
structure an incentive where if I really
knock it out the park I can make three
times my salary this year versus this
kind of like 10K you know salary Gap um
but you know I I guess obviously not
everybody cares that way or thinks that
way but uh
I don't know it seems like of of 100 of
the population it seems like at least 20
of the population should be asking
themselves those types of questions more
often
um in the same way that like
before I met any business people I just
thought like when oh after college you
go get a job I didn't think there were
other options and only once I saw that
there's these other options in that man
there's people doing business they seem
to be having a lot more fun and making
more money like okay I guess I could go
do that it's like you just sometimes
need to see it or hear it and then it
changes the way you think and I think
more people should see or hear the
question of like how do I make three
times more in half the time how do I
make 10 times more total how do I have
twice the fun on the same salary how do
I twice the time on the same salary it's
like there are just better questions you
can ask yourself that the ones really
although I will say one thing that I
really miss you do you guys remember we
started that business called buyer where
it was negotiation that was an awesome
idea yeah amazing idea amazing guy who
ran it kimya
um we ended up selling it to ramp
um I didn't really want to sell it but
for Kimia it was like his first big
access so so it made a lot of sense and
we're really excited for him but I
really missed that business because
that's one thing where I'm just too busy
running my business to negotiate things
and you know when I'm buying like a car
or you know doing a um I don't know any
like a big buy of furniture or like a
renovation or anything I still want that
so I really I put this out to the
audience someone needs to restart that
business negotiation as a service that's
in the cube that's a great Nick Huber
business I agree are you gonna make
money on the stock of ramp ramped is
does good I think we we didn't we didn't
take stop stock we just took cash
because we for us we could just take the
money and invest it ourselves so we knew
we could get a good return within tiny
dude these are the best podcasts these
are the best podcasts so we're just what
we're just hanging out uh I wonder if
the listener prefers these where it's uh
like it just hangs but I like those
better personally yeah that was super
fun guys if you like it compliment us
into YouTube comments if you don't like
it
well you're probably gone by now thank
you
[Music]
foreign